good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the press and
public I welcome you to this meeting of
the council if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices via
the stairs I have through the security
doors to my right or opposite the lifts
in the foyer please do not use the lifts
please assemble in holy square on the
green on the green officers will assist
you and advise when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber the Proceedings of
this meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the Internet I
would advise that the filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
areas may have their images captured I
urge anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
[Applause]
any member of the public who objects to
the possibility of being filmed may wish
to take this opportunity to leave the
meeting any filming or recording will
not be permitted for any item of
business where exempt or confidential
information is considered following
following the exclusion of the press and
public from the meeting would everyone
present please ensure that their mobile
phones are turned to silent and that
they are not used to make or receive
phone calls in the chamber whilst this
meeting is in progress
agenda item 1 apologies for absence
apologies have been received from
councilors constantine and gregory are
there any other apologies councillor
Braidwood
madam jana
thank you
Oh railroad counselor Braidwood yeah
agenda item two minutes of previous
meetings he held on the 22nd of February
2018 I move that the minutes of the
meeting of the council held on the 22nd
of February 2018 be approved and signed
as a correct record with the vice
chairman please second seconds in do
members agree thank you minutes of the
extraordinary meeting held on the 1st of
March 2018 I move that the minutes of
the extraordinary meeting held on the of
the council held on the 1st of March
2018 be approved and signed as a correct
record would the vice chairman please
second seconded no members agree thank
you
agenda item 4 announcements I have not
been informed of any announcements
gender item 5 declarations of interests
are there any declarations of interests
agenda item
doo-doo-doo-doo 14 changes to members
allowance scheme I should think we're
all there
yes there is a general dispensation in
place regard to remember the Lance's
agenda item six petitions no petitions
have been received in accordance with
council procedure rule number twelve
agenda item seven questions from the
press and public to questions have been
received from members of the public in
accordance with council procedure rule
number thirteen
please note that only the questioner and
respondent are permitted to speak on the
question and that if the questioner is
not present at this meeting their
question cannot be put but will be
replied to in writing could the
questioner please only state the name of
the cabinet member to whom their
question is to be put and read out their
exact wording of the question that they
submitted to the council agenda item 7a
question number one from a member of the
public impact on uses of clinical waste
and sharps disposal services and pleased
to welcome miss Clark to the meeting
could you please make your way to the
top table
okay the question was for the person in
charge of the waste and recycling I'm
not sure of the exact title question is
was any thought given to the impact on
users at the clinical waste and sharps
disposal service under the Equality Act
of 2010 when charges were being
considered as those who use the service
are being treated unfavorably as a
consequence of their disability thank
you miss Clark
I called Punk counts of Taylor Swift to
answer Taylor Smith to respond get me
tea free make you chairman and thank you
for your question miss Clark
firstly I should like to offer an
apology on behalf of the council for the
incorrect information sent out to some
residents this happened before I became
cabinet member for environmental
services and for the upset concern and
confusion caused for the users of our
clinical waste services an equality
impact assessment was carried out by
officers as part of the consideration to
introduce fees and charges for clinical
waste collection and this was undertaken
to ensure compliance with the controlled
waste England and Wales regulations 2012
which allows local authorities to charge
for clinical and medical waste
collection services
agenda item 7b question number 2 from a
member of the public health and safety
implications of the changes to the
clinical waste and sharps disposal
service I am pleased to welcome is Noah
to the meeting could you please make
your way to the top table
thank you this is also for councillor
Taylor Smith was any thought given to
the implication under health and safety
legislation when users of clinical waste
and sharps disposal were originally told
they could use their black bin for
disposal of waste if an employee or
member of the public received an injury
who would be liable thank you miss lord
I call upon councillor Taylor Smith to
respond Thank You chairman and thank you
for questions northward firstly I should
like to reiterate categorically that
needles and other clinical waste should
never be placed into household bins for
collection for clarification what can go
in a household bin includes nappies
incontinence pads stoma bags
non-infectious dressings but the advice
is to double bag them I want to assure
you that the council did not take the
decision to introduce charges for
clinical waste collections lightly we a
fennec District Council have listened to
recent feedback from users of the
clinical waste service who are directly
affected by these proposed changes
charges sorry and we are now carefully
considering all the concerns raised and
in order to do this we are deferring
indefinitely the implementation of these
charges until we have untape undertaken
a wider review informed by comments from
our residents clinical waste users
health partners health groups and
elected members and just sorry the last
part of your question I just wanted to
address that Miss North with the
officers are taking advice on the issue
of liability that you mentioned thank
you agenda item eight questions from
members of the council six questions
have been received from members however
question three
agenda item eight seen regarding
outsourcing of council services has been
withdrawn from the agenda at the request
of the councillor who submitted it
please note that the time allowed for
consideration of questions from members
shall not exceed 30 minutes without the
leave of the chair this can only be
granted in exceptional circumstances so
I ask members to be succinct and to
avoid repetition where possible with
members please refer to the
supplementary agenda item number 1 for
questions 4 5 & 6 agenda item 8 a
question number 1 from from a member
regarding the postponement of clinical
waste in sharp disposal services
I call upon councilor matter face Thank
You chair my question is for councillor
Taylor Smith and it's obviously on the
similar topic the postponement of fees
and charges for clinical waste and
sharps disposal is welcome but what
alternatives are under consideration and
how long will the users of the service
have to wait to find out the options
I call upon councillor Taylor Smith to
respond Thank You chairman thank you for
your question count aslam atif ace we
will continue to deliver the clinical
waste collection free of charge whilst a
review is carried out with Health
Partners health groups and clinical
waste service users counselors are also
invited to contribute and I hope that
this review will be concluded within the
next few months officers have already
met with the NHS Anna Clinic Clinical
Commissioning group and there will be
further meetings with other help groups
and partners to appraise all available
options and we will continue to take on
board feedback from users of this
service to help inform future decision
council Amata faced you do you have a
supplementary question in the fees and
charges that were passed in December
last year this item was included the
question may actually have been more
suitably addressed at this point to
cancel the Gregory but perhaps
councillor Taylor Smith can take on
board in that fees and charges 60,000
pounds was the estimate
revenue obviously another source of
revenue will have to be found but I hope
that it will not be the clinical waste
and I would also like to ask assurances
that any developments in the future the
Environmental Protection Act of 1990
will be include you have mentioned the
controlled waste regulations there's
also the hazard of hazardous waste
directive 2011 and the carriage of
dangerous goods of regulations as well
and I hope they will all be taken into
account when a platter future plan is
approved thank you I call upon
councillor Taylor Smith to respond Thank
You chairman I believe that might have
been a statement rather than the
question but I can assure a council a
matter face that all those matters will
be taken into account thank you the
question about funding I cannot answer
at this stage chairman but I'm sure that
colleagues will get back to councilor
motivation to your course thank you
agenda item 8 8b christendom number tool
from a member regarding projects in
Margate Central Ward I call upon
councillor Johnston thank you very much
chairman this is a question for the
leader of the council the new leader of
the council what efforts have you made
since becoming leader to progress
several projects and help us in Margate
Central Ward in fairness to councillor
Beaufort I had actually listed eight
items but I was asked to remove them so
I hope you know what projects I'm
talking about thank you I call upon the
leader to respond in that case
councillor Johnson I can tell you I
don't know the eight that you referring
to but I'm sure you are aware of the
excellent work being done by our offices
in Margate we've got some ambitious
objectives including reduction of
deprivation and health inequalities
creating a more sustainable community
creating new quality affordable housing
and we have had success and he privately
rented homes have been made safe by
enforcement many residents help with
wider health and welfare named
bad landlord Priven out with 39
prosecuted less anti-social behavior and
fewer empty homes counsel continues to
work in partnership with SHL and its
investors in dreamland I'm sure that all
councillors would join me in
congratulating our staff and our
partners who work on these projects all
right we give them very much I do have a
further question because obviously I
know all of what you've listed because I
constantly report those issues in the
ward as does councillor of edibles but
my list the eight that you didn't do
about is now 15 that you didn't know
about so the fort hotel the Theatre
Royal 19 holy square the barn in King
Street
the mayor's parlor and Museum to revert
the decision of removal of the 350 K
which may lead to the closure of the
Winter Gardens
thank you for reverting and kept the
cancelling of the counseling the charge
is to feel good that was very kind of
you but then the addition to the list
now is security measures have been
asking for for two years now at meeting
Court the work that should have been
done at church feels at the end of 2015
store 21 a new street which our council
owned properties that have been empty
for some time the chasing of the owners
at Primark and Woolworths who have I've
got written to officers about the
planning permissions of what we're
making the people do to clean up their
buildings Arlington a report should have
come to cover this a long time ago
the wayfaring project in our ward and of
course the shelters that's 15 items none
of which you mentioned and I'm sorry
that your officers haven't told you that
these are items I raised all the time so
please could either you tell me when
you'll have items on these 15 coming to
your cabinet which I see you recently
cancelled I call upon the leader to
respond Johnson yeah I appreciate the
long list that you've got and I hope you
all appreciate that I don't actually
have 15 answers for you right now
what I'm prepared to do is to have a
meeting with you in the next couple of
weeks and I will be brief on all those
items and we can discuss them in full
[Music]
no agenda item 8d question number four
from a member regarding plastic waste
I call upon councilor messenger Thank
You chairman the question is to
counselor Rosanna Taylor Smith Blue
Planet have highlighted to the world how
plastics have become a detriment to our
sea life and environment will the
council now look to adopt a policy to
work towards a plastic free coastline
I call upon councillor Taylor Smith to
respond Thank You chairman and thank you
for your question counselor messenger
sorry I can't turn around to look at you
with my answer I welcome your question
and I'm happy to endorse your suggestion
that tannic district council works
towards a plastic free coastline and I
hope that when I bring back to Council
our approach in due course all members
will support it will also have to wait
and see what the government proposals
are on plastics as well briefly members
may be aware that this council is
supporting the surface against sewage
plastic free coastline campaign and
several if you join the beach clean last
weekend in Margate there is another one
you're all welcome Saturday 10 o'clock
on Viking Bay Broadstairs this council
has been working with Keep Britain Tidy
on a research project to prevent Beach
litter Margate Maine Sands was chosen
for this study because of the various
amenities concessions on the beach
number of summer visitors and proximity
to the town and railway station this has
given an excellent insight into the main
causes of each litter and we are now
waiting for feedback from Keith Britain
Tidy on actions we can take this summer
to change behavior of both visitors and
local beach users this could include
include changes to bins signage working
with local businesses etc but we will
focus strictly on the evidence produced
and what will make a difference to
litter on our beaches throughout the
district we continue to promote our
two-minute beach clean and hope to ride
reusable woven bags very soon we're
thinking about offering the public a
badge in return for this beach clean as
we think this would be popular with
families and we encourage them to post
their work on social media using the
hashtag 2-minute beach clean we also
promote the Marine Conservation Society
annual plastic challenge which
encourages people to give up plastic for
a month in the hope that they will
reduce their plastic consumption long
term also our Education Officer has
produced a booklet for children which is
distributed to schools and community
groups this tackles marine and other
litter dog fouling and recycling and how
all these factors affect global warning
and climate change none of this could be
done without the excellent voluntary
groups here in Thanet and I'm going to
mention a few of them and apologies if I
don't mention them or Broadstairs town
team and Ramsgate town team and I'm sure
there's many more Thank You councillor
Mason's you do you have a supplementary
question Thank You chairman I wonder
then can we aim like Manchester City
Council to take steps to ban single-use
plastic items from our district by 2020
I call upon councillor Taylor Smith to
respond Thank You councillor messenger I
certainly hope that TDC will do its very
best to meet that thank you
agenda item 8a question number 5 from a
member regarding eradication of litter
I call upon councillor Dawson thank you
madam chair this question is to our
leader board both words I think you'll
all agree that the litter has become a
hot topic of conversation for residents
across done it so in order to motivate
others into action we need to be active
so that everyone benefits we have a
beautiful aisle to live on and we need
to make certain is kept tidy we need to
be working together using a hands-on
approach it will mean focusing on
forming a focus group led by a strong
team of dedicated and enthusiastic
members who are willing to push forward
ideas to brainstorm and find it will be
at the end because you can have a to two
minutes can I make a point of order the
question has to be where does in the
agenda yes and it is permissible to have
an introduction to the question before
posing the question
okay
right we need to be working time okay
counsel Dawson can you please just ask
your question we need to be working
together using hands-on approach it
would mean focusing it would be
informing a focus group led by a strong
team of dedicated and enthusiastic
members who are willing to push forward
ideas to brainstorm and find not only a
practical solution but a creative
solution and work cross-party took
together towards eradicating litter and
plastics for our streets and beaches you
may have seen campaigns over the years
to keep Britain Tidy in the 1970s when I
was a child it was a tidy man logo
dropping litter into a beam which is
used today but has been replaced by the
Green Man instead and a series such as
the one balls who collected and recycled
rubbish in ways their motto being make
use of bad rubbish the principle is
still as important today if not more so
it is true there were already
established projects out there and I
feel there are massive opportunities and
benefits available if we are thought to
share and Link in with other groups in
order to fight the war on litter at
present the groups appear to be working
in isolation and we do need to be
working in Elmsford Orson would you
please just ask your question would the
leader support a working party which is
cross-party to oversee and promote a
funny awareness and educational campaign
to eradicate litter and plastics on our
streets and beaches thank you
I call upon the leader to respond thanks
Jeff thank you for your question in
councillor Dawson as can be seen from
the previous cabinet members answers we
are working hard to improve our streets
and beaches and officers are looking
into an umbrella campaign to tackle all
of our environmental issues and
communicate the messages in a more
consistent way officers are working
directly with local residents to develop
this approach and we're grateful to
everyone who attended our recent focus
group which generated a number of new
ideas and initiatives for the council to
take forward jointly with the community
I welcome your personal initiative
councillor Dawson and fully support it
you've also told me about some of the
activities that you're involved in that
you didn't mention there which are going
to raise awareness of the issues it's a
great example of how accounts that can
use that position to help the community
today we represent you will obviously
choose the most appropriate ways to take
this forward but you might also want to
speak to the chair of overview and
scrutiny panel about whether a working
party on litter and waste could be
included in the panel's work program
Council Dawson do you have a
supplementary question
agenda item 8f question number six from
remember regarding littering fines I
call upon councillor Larkins
thank you madam chair most of the
correspondence from residents in East
Cliff Ward is about the vast amounts of
litter strewn around the area with a
permitted litter fine increase by
central government I beg the question
can TDC increased litter fine in line
with this new legislation as it
deterrence place I call upon council
Taylor Smith to respond Thank You
chairman and thank you for your question
councillor Larkins as you may be aware
in April 2017 the government launched a
new litter strategy for England with an
ambition to be the generation to leave
the natural environment of England in a
better state than it found it the
strategy is to apply best practice in
education enforcement and infrastructure
to deliver a substantial reduction
litter and littering behavior the new
legislation the environmental offences
fixed penalties England regulations 2017
came into effect on the first of April
2018 and officers are currently looking
at all the options and implications for
implementing the higher fine for
littering we are also waiting for
statuary statutory guidance do very soon
which will advise officers how to take
into account circumstances like a
person's ability to pay when considering
implementing the higher fine also for
the first time outside London we will be
able to apply these penalties for
littering to vehicle owners if it can be
proved that litter was thrown from their
car even if it was thrown by another
person councillor Larkins do you have a
supplementary question yes madam chair I
think the maximum penalty is 150 pounds
a can we race the fine up 250 pounds and
be can we employ more litter ward
thank you I call upon councillor Taylor
Smith to respond Thank You councillor
Larkins I refer to my previous answer
yes we can do but I think we should wait
until we actually get the guidance
because maybe you will agree it's
probably not worth putting the fine up
too high for not going to actually get
that money I think it does depend on
circumstances and I think there are
plans to add to the enforcement team but
I'm quite happy to get back to you with
with further details and due course
thank you agenda item 9 motions
unnoticed no motions on notice have been
received in accordance with council
procedure rule 3 agenda item 10 leaders
report I call upon the leader Thank You
chair one of the first issues we had to
deal with us a new administration was
the upset caused by the introduction of
charges for the collection of clinical
waste which has been referenced already
this evening in my opinion it wasn't a
good decision and it was a a grave ated
by poor implementation it highlighted
the need to consult service users when
making changes and the importance of
effective communication as a result a
decision has been made to put our
customers our residents at the heart of
everything we do and to carefully
consider the impact on them of our
actions before rather than after the
event fact is that council gets it right
isn't the story whereas even the
smallest mistake we make becomes
headline news you also heard earlier
about some of the steps we are taking to
address the curse of litter in the
district this has to be a high priority
as it blights our streets and beaches
making the environment unpleasant I'm
pleased to report that CDC recently
secured 34 prosecutions for non-payment
of fixed penalty notices for littering
we also achieved three successful
prosecutions for fly-tipping thanks the
tough action taken by the council
additionally we secured the landmark
premises
on a property in Broadstairs to prevent
cooker win and associated antisocial
behavior I believe that whilst education
will play an important role in changing
the public's behavior it has to be
backed up by effective enforcement and
it will be our policy to support firm
and fair enforcement activity across all
areas where it's appropriate
this will include planning and perhaps
especially parking we've all seen
examples of inconsiderate parking that
inconvenience is us and worse parking in
places where it's downright dangerous
we're committed to stop in this we hope
to engage residents more in helping to
make fanuc a better place to live and
we'll be actively engaging with them to
seek their views we recently held a
residence focused group on the topic of
clean streets were presently reviewing
the feedback with a view to responding
to the ideas which were forthcoming we
all have a responsibility to keep our
communities tidy and I believe that we
can improve the way that TDC and fennecs
residents and visitors might work
together to tack with this persistent
costly and avoidable problem you will
recall the dreadful weather that we
experienced at the beginning of March
the council activated its severe weather
emergency plan and also extended the
opening of the winter shelter by a week
up to the 5th of March waste and
recycling collections suffered severe
disruption because of the difficult
conditions but all delayed collections
were picked up by the end of the
following week I would like to recognize
the exceptional efforts that were made
by our crews at that time I think it's
important that TDC should work closely
with town and parish councils to ensure
that we're practicable decisions are
made and services are provided by the
tier of local government closest to the
residents in this context I'm pleased to
advise that the ownership of Piermont
Hall in Broadstairs
has transferred from TDC to Broadstairs
and simply discount town council I've
taken a decision to reduce the size of
cabinet of one member to facilitate this
I'm taking on some portfolio
responsibilities myself but colleagues
are also happy to accept wider
responsibilities I'll be bringing
forward shortly a proposed
to create cabinet assistant posts which
will not only take some of the pressure
off cabinet members but will also help
with succession planning I'm very
conscious that I lead a minority
administration and I feel that it's
appropriate that other parties were
involved in the council's journey I will
be bringing forward a proposal to create
a group consisting of myself and
councillor Savage matter face Stewart
Piper and worlds together with the
senior management team to adjust with
Egypt matters that affect EDC I will
further be proposing that the chair and
vice chair positions on this council are
shared by all parties on a proportional
basis tonight I will be proposing that
non-executive positions on outside
bodies should be at annual council
allocated to those willing and best
suited to carrying out those tasks from
whichever party turning to the local
plane as you are aware the Secretary of
State for housing Communities and Local
Government
Sajid Javid wrote to this council in
March indicating that he was intervening
in our local plan process the messages
from the ministry however were positive
emphasizing that the intention was to
help to help sorry the intention was to
help then accelerate the production of
its local plan I welcome this as our
number one priority on taking control
was to bring forward the date of
submission for examination of our plan
from April 2019 this was a date proposed
by the previous administration we had
our first meeting with the government
planner this week and he assured us that
he and his team were not here to write a
local plan their job was to assess where
we are in the process and how we got
here they would then recommend to the
Secretary of State the fastest way to
produce an appropriate plan for Senate
we explained that we were all working on
bringing the day for submission forward
to later this year and we will be
sending them a detailed timetable
showing how we will achieve this we were
also advised to continue work on
preparing the plan I'm confident the
null alternative approach could produce
a plan quicker but it would be unwise to
be complacent and I'll keep members
informed of our program
unrelated matter it was announced this
week that RSP have now submitted their
DCI application the progress of which we
will be monitoring closely at a meeting
with RSP yesterday it was agreed also
that they would make a presentation to
all members possibly in June to end on a
truly positive note in the short time
that I've been leader of TDC I've been
impressed by the quality and commitment
of our officers despite the challenges
of budget cuts they continue to serve
our community with enthusiasm and
nowhere is this more apparent than in
our housing department at the
prestigious local government awards
ceremony recently they wonder 2018 LGC
housing initiative Ward for their work
on Margate live project the team
produced outcomes which the judges
described as demonstrating a successful
and sustained sustained tragedy I can't
say that I start that again
it's worth hearing properly the judges
described demonstrate than demonstrating
a successful and sustained strategy to
deal with a very challenging housing
problem
it showed showcases clear interventions
partner and community and engagement
bravery and tenacity
I almost said at that time that was
alright and TDC has also been shortly
shortlisted for to further Awards so
many congratulations to all those
involved thank you
I call upon counselor Reverend Piper to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leaders report thank you madam
chair thank you for your report council
abated and also for the assurance that
you approve of introductions so may I as
leader of the largest single political
group in opposition which was
established to try and give a voice to
the people of Thanet focusing on their
aspirations rather than party politics
join with the right honourable Sajid
Javid in welcoming you to your recent
appointment as leader of the council I
noted that he effectively went on to be
quite critical of all those councillors
who put you in this position but as you
might expect I do not share his views on
that point 35 of us believed the
decision taken on January the 18th was
the right one and that it would at least
give us a chance of meaningful
discussion with the Secretary of State's
team to try and impress upon them among
other things the reality of our local
situation regarding housing need
deliverability and his excessive housing
numbers the choice you have picked up is
not without challenge or even a trace or
two of poison but you have at least
picked it up and set out in this first
report just some of the key issues to be
faced I welcome your determination to be
more open and put our residents at the
heart of all our endeavors and who knows
perhaps that will in the end lead to a
headline that says council gets it right
at least please don't let us be boring
let us engage enthusiastically with our
residents the winter shelter program is
the envy of many councils I'm sure and
the team deserve every accolade afforded
to them as to those responsible for the
implementation of the severe weather
emergency protocols not all councils run
both I welcome to your plans to involve
leaders together with the senior
management team to address strategic
matters for this come out of this
council good communication is going to
be paramount for the next 12 months or
so if we are to show the public that
we're working constructively for the
Bennett
of all of our communities the sword of
damocles has not fallen and it is good
to note that the chief planner is to
examine what we've done and then offer
help and advice on an appropriate way
forward on that note man I just
mentioned that it is good to see that
several members appear to have vacated
their nuclear shelters and joined us for
this evening's proceedings their absence
that the previous two meetings was
noticeable the housing team have
achieved great successes recently and
the award is most certainly merited too
often there are more brickbats and
bouquets for them and they should be
proud of their achievements
perhaps I can leave you with a little
riddle that you don't have to answer at
the moment but I'm happy to give you the
answer later on when does 13 plus 1 not
equate to 14 thank you madam chair I
call upon the leader to respond just
thank councillor Chris comments chair I
call upon my khalaf and council wells to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leaders report asking English
this report and a very straight for one
used to talk in some detail about having
non politically biased to reports live
congratulations your first report and I
I hope there will be many more like that
just two things ray I'd like to comment
on all or all point entry I'll be
fascinated by your analysis which allows
you to produce something for April 2019
because there was a very clear timetable
I think that was discussed at the time
and in the local plan working group that
led us at that point so we'll be really
interested to see what do you think you
can cut out of that on route and and
secondly just yes ad congratulations to
certainly the awards at the house of
teams run along several other awards
that have come out of what was a very
successful cross body cooperation which
was called the approval board we
and you were there that meeting when it
was decided at the improvement panel
that we will actually put TDC officers
forward for awards to actually
demonstrate the nature of the journey
that we've been on and this is one such
event that has actually come to fruition
because we did all work successfully I
call upon the leader to respond okay
thank Council well Swiss comments thank
you I call upon councilor matter face to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leaders report Thank You chair
the premises closure order that was
referenced in your draft that you sent
me was extremely welcome I have to pat
myself on the back I did have quite a
bit of input into that and residents
tell me that it is at the time for the
time being it is a great deal quieter
and thanks again to the housing
department work in conjunction with
orbit and the police I've got a few
questions for you we did discuss as
group leaders having a two-year
moratorium and part of the local plan I
would be interested to know if you have
any intentions of reviving that and also
mr. Javid had talked about working with
other councils so can you update us or
give us some kind of indication whether
you consider that the local plan in its
current form you will anticipate working
with other councils in its production
housing numbers councillor Piper has
already referenced those can you give us
any date have you had any clues in your
meeting how the housing numbers are
likely to go there's a lot of
speculation on that and I was quite
surprised to discover I have been
appointed to strategic matters
cross-party is very welcome but could
you please enlighten me before I accept
the offer what exactly I am likely to be
strategically mattering on thank you
I call upon the leader to respond
okay if I press that one first I mean I
I thought it had become widely known I
was intending to create something that
had been badly known by me the oversight
board because that implies that you pick
up the things we didn't get right and
that wasn't the intention now I mean I
think council world was probably got
closest to the kind of definition it is
a an effort to replicate the improvement
ball except it's not just about
improvement it's about looking at you
know the way forth of this council and I
do think it's really important that we
do all work together and you know and
it's it seems to work tonight it may be
that's just lucky here but we'll see as
far as your questions are on the local
planner concerns I mean the situation is
to say we didn't know what to expect
when we had to meet him with the chief
planner and say what we've been advised
to do is to carry on working on our
plane and it would be improper at this
stage to really comment on where we are
with that as far as working with other
councils that hasn't been put on the
agenda that appeared in in service
letter I'm sure if I missed anything
else about local thing no I was saying I
think it's premature to talk about how
the plan may actually come out of this
of this process thank you
agenda item 11 annual report chairman of
the overview and scrutiny panel
I call upon councillor David Saunders to
present his report Thank You chairman
before I present the annual report on
behalf of my fellow members and the
overview and scrutiny pan I'd like to
give my personal thanks to the officers
in democratic services and in particular
to Charles hungry for their help and
assistance over the past year members
Lee report before you this evening
highlights some of the panels Kipps
activities and achievements over the
2000
17/18 municipal year the current
scrutiny arrangements are shown on page
31 and as members will see in 2.2 we
have adopted a system of prioritizing
scrutiny review projects which is
intended to enable the panel to conduct
their work more efficiently and for
members to focus on issues that would
add value to the decision making process
for the council and help improve service
delivery to our residents also and with
a view to encouraging both transparency
and inclusiveness we have extended the
scheme of allowing public speaking of
scrutiny meetings and making it very
short but if I could just add we've had
the issue of littering raised this
evening and on Tuesday of this week the
Community Safety Partnership Working
Party met and had a very interesting and
informative presentation by Kevin Kevin
behind me and I understood so I
understand that all members would have
received an email of the slides and the
information and I'm sure that in the new
municipal year littering will be raised
using the new arrangements that I've
just outlined and bring it to scrutiny
so that we can review it in more detail
thank you - thank you
agenda item 12 annual report chairman
and chairman of the governance and audit
committee
I call upon councillor Buckley to
present his report Thank You chair
excuse me if I could draw members
attention to the annual governance and
audit report set out on page 39
agenda item 12 and X 1 as you are aware
on an annual basis the governance and
Audit Committee goes through a
self-assessment process to understand
its performance against its terms of
reference this information then feeds
into the annual report which is before
you this evening the
the report provides detail of the
attendance of meetings the reports
considered by the committee and the
outcome of the self-assessment it also
identifies any future challenges for the
committee and actions to improve its
effectiveness I therefore propose that
members have proved the content of the
annual report and the recommended
actions within the action plan and as
with the chairman of the skirt and he
may I take this opportunity to thank all
members of the governance and audit
committee members and officers who have
contributed and also thank the officers
for throughout the municipal year excuse
me for the last convoluted sentence
thank you thank you
agenda item 13 annual report chairman of
of standards committee I call upon dr.
Sexton to present his report dr. Sexton
please can you come to the front bench
sure members have received the report
and have had the opportunity to reflect
on the observations contained within it
I have nothing further or substance to
add other than to commend the report to
Council thank you thank you
cancel house I've got to be rather
careful to contain myself because this
is a disgusting report not only was it
completely well not completely but not
fact you the the author of it did not in
any way shape or form look into the
facts of it but my sister house will you
please manage your language what did I
say well disgusting is inappropriate
well I don't believe it could you repeat
back what I said that was out of order
you can carry on but you need to be
mindful of what you're saying I'm an
elected councillor chair and I represent
my constituents of old Burton South I
have on many occasions written on
Facebook that I and largely guided by
their opinions and not my own
regardless sometimes I vote well it's
not my opinion this was a discussing but
the way I'm not so worried about
the report but I'm more worried about
the officers that allowed my integrity
to be impugned that I think we've heard
enough counts no I don't think you heard
you please sit down
no I stand up they're not you can stand
up all you like I'm here to represent my
constituents and that man is not going
to write will adjourn the meeting can we
call this meeting to order please
counselor house you've got 20 seconds to
say to finish saying what you wanted to
say would you if you've got anything to
say would you please say in an
appropriate manner freedom of speech I
saw well I have to say freedom of speech
and if I said in any appropriate words I
apologize but I don't believe I did the
councillor Linda paper I wish to place
on record my disapproval concerning
paragraph 610 of the standards committee
report the report proffered personal
opinion about the way certain elected
members voted at Council on the 22nd of
February it also invites other members
to speculate as to the motives behind
that groups voting decision I was not
asked personally why I voted as I did in
my view the report should not comment on
the way any elected member exercises
their right to vote as they see fit in
this chamber nor does anyone have the
right to malign my character and
integrity in a public document where I
do not have any right of reply if this
paragraph is not removed it would set a
precedent whereby council officers or
appointees would have carte blanche to
use official reports as a means of
unjustly criticizing the way members
vote Matt madam chair would be a
dangerous precedent
indeed surely we have the Democratic
right to vote as we wish without
incurring such scathing and factually
incorrect criticism in a public document
Thank You councillor Taylor Thank You
Chet lots of points out on the standards
report that 6/10 isn't completely
correct it says that um we voted on
block well I can say I can surely say
that we didn't I didn't even vote that
night also a chair did not ask her any
abstentions this needs to be obviously
improved in any other voting in future
possible please Thank You councillor
broom thank you madam chair with regards
to a school paragraph 6.10 I've actually
raised a public disclosure with regards
to the behavior that went on that night
and I'm still waiting for a response
from the chief executive and the
monitoring officer with regards to
paragraph 3.1 this public report has
made assumptions regarding elected
members which are misleading and
damaging there are many reasons why
member might need to leave a meeting
earlier than intended and I'm surprised
about the lack of truth in this report
regarding members behavior and I believe
it to be vexatious political frivolous
tip-tap
councillor Stewart paper thank you madam
chair this report was first published in
the public arena just a few days after
the council meeting of the 22nd of
February the date is significant because
paragraphs 610 of the report refers to
that meeting the report was published
without consideration for its accuracy
and despite several attempts having been
made to have the report revised there
seems to have been a determination to
persist with this wholly inaccurate and
misleading paragraph 610 does not offer
any evidence to substantiate the remarks
nor does it indicate that any codes of
practice may have been breached the
author seems to have got a little
carried away and being unwilling to
accept any error in simple terms 610 is
in my view a bit of a rant about the way
some elected members chose to vote as
far as I'm aware criticism of the voting
decisions of any members in any public
report does not fall within the remit of
any council officer or appointee
I believe the situation has been
completely misunderstood and I believe
the author should have at least asked a
question or two for clarity before
committing his words to a public report
I have been disappointed madam chair
that despite meetings at the highest
level I've been unable to persuade
anybody of the inappropriate nature of
this rant nevertheless the point needs
to be made I believe that such behavior
taken upon oneself can never be
acceptable ironically this report if
accepted without condemnation or any
amendments at all would set a dangerous
precedent
it would give permission to publish on a
public platform allegations of our
elected members without fear of
retribution something that was not
afforded to the councillor who was
charged with a very similar offence
I would like to advise members that this
report is the subject of more than one
formal complaint because members have
felt their character and integrity has
been attacked without justification I
have been clearly identified though not
named and singled out for specific
unfounded
criticism and I am one who has lodged a
formal complaint it is my understanding
madam chair that if counsel notes this
report this evening as it stands we are
neither accepting it or approving of its
contents but merely noting that it has
been written I may however be wrong so I
would appreciate some clarity on that
point madam chair because I cannot or
accept or approve of this report with
paragraph 6/10 remaining
thank you yes like am I agree with your
view the council simply receiving the
report neither at neither endorsing it
nor not endorsing it they're receiving
the report as delivered dr. sexton do
you want to add anything to that Thank
You chair I am independently appointed
to hold up a mirror to members from time
to time to reflect on conduct in the
chamber and outside the observations
made in that report in my report are
frankly factually accurate I will not
change it thank you
counselor counselor in the paper you've
already spoken you're not allowed to
speak again counselor Johnson thank you
it's just a point that counselor tailor
made he was very clear that he did not
vote on the night and yet it says in the
report on block I think that that needs
to be corrected if members of that group
didn't all vote in support of counselor
Piper's concerns on the night that in
you know if we're going to move forward
as a council that works for the good of
our community we need to get everything
right and whatever whatever political
differences we have if a member says
that he didn't vote in that way and he
didn't follow the lead of everybody else
on that new team there that needs to be
corrected in that report we're not in a
position to correct the report the
report is the report but you might want
to noted in the minutes of this meeting
that's what's been said thank you thank
you
are you actually saying that on the
basis of what that was just been said
that the report was actually wrong no
never seen it what's wrong what we're
saying is it's been noted there
agenda item 14 changes to the members
allowance scheme the members want to
note the report yes okay agenda item 14
changes to the members allowance scheme
I call upon the leader very difficult to
follow all with that chair I would just
like to move the recommendation
recommendations one to six but with the
following slightly altered
recommendation - which is to agree
introduction of five SRS for portfolio
assistance to be paid at a rate of
fifteen hundred pounds each and that
proposals to allocate the savings made
from the deletion of the shadow cabinet
post be brought to annual council thank
you is there a second baptists a second
that madam chair do members agree thank
you
agenda item could you tell me who on the
opposition side seeing they've both got
14 more or less who's getting the
opposition alliances at the moment thank
you
nobody the money for cleaning my ward
then attender item 15 pay policy
statement financial year 2018 19 with
members please refer to supplementary
supplementary agenda number one I call
upon the leader vote recommendation
chairman is there a second happy to
second that madam chair do members
counts council phoner thank you
I note the Equality Duty assessment was
carried out for this policy but nowhere
in this policy can I see any mechanism
to monitor the parity of pay between
genders the gender pay gap has been
reported in the public domain for many
organizations so we cannot assume that
TDC is always going to be immune to it
there needs to be active monitoring of a
gender pay gap within these the pay
structure therefore I would like to
propose an amendment or addendum as a
new paragraph paragraph 6 we could call
it gender pay gap and it would read a
mechanism will be set up to monitor
regularly the gender pay gap at TDC and
report to Council
I'll move can i okay sorry interrupt at
that point the pay policy statement is a
statutory document
the requirements of the Localism Act and
it sets our particular quirements of
what we need to include in the pay
policy statement in terms of gender pay
gap gender equality we also have a
separate statutory obligation to do that
as well but that happens outside the pay
policy statement so the work continues
we do do work on the gender pay gap and
I have recently completed that work but
it's not part of the pay policy
statement because it doesn't relate to
how we pay our staff it's got nothing to
do with how we pay our staff or how the
remunerated as a completely different
separate issue and therefore should not
be in the pay policy statement we should
be Caroline if you're doing that how
will she report it separately - oh yeah
I still need to know what mechanism is
going to be set up to monitor the pain
where they sit what where is it where
where is that mechanism I'll ensure that
the link is provided to all members off
this meeting councillor whales yeah this
is a similar thing really which is but
also not just provide the link but can
you just provide us all with the
guidance of when this comes to council
wrote in the same way as the pay policy
statement has and which Polly
legislation sits with them how the two
sit together
do members agree thank you agenda item
16 changes to the council's Constitution
I move that the recommendations are set
out in the report be adopted with the
vice chairman please second second madam
chairman thank you do members agree
counsel brain thank you madam chairman I
feel that before you start implementing
further change to the Constitution staff
the senior members of staff needs to be
getting the basics right and learn how
to walk before they run in part two of
the Constitution councilor brim we're
not going down that road again
well we're not referencing we're not
referencing officers with derogatory
right so I go back to item in part two
of the Constitution item one zero three
paragraph three the Constitution states
that the purpose of the Constitution is
to help counselors represent their cost
constituents effectively if our
questions that we're asking in the
chambers are being repeatedly not
answered by people put before them in
Council and the counselor Bremen I'm not
into dually people polling to answer the
questions or by giving a written
response and you are trying to alter the
Constitution by not allowing members the
opportunity to ask the same question in
a six month time limit counseling will
you place this held how it's the
brainiest represent their constituent
as monetary officer I'm responsible for
reviewing and updating them our
Constitution as appropriate so it'd be
really helpful if counts have been were
to contact me
and express her concerns and then if
necessary I can bring them to a
Constitution review Working Party we
should then bring it up to standards
committee and then to Council so I think
we can't do it on the hoof here because
that's not what our procedure allows but
I think it'd be helpful for a discussion
to explain your concerns I'll pick them
up and take them forward as necessary do
members agree thank you agenda item 17
representation on outside bodies I call
upon the leader Thank You chair as I
indicated earlier I think that the right
way for this list to be put together is
that it's complete cross-party that we
put the most appropriate person who
wants to do the job from whatever party
on that list so for tonight what I would
like to propose and I may need some help
with the wording is that the list has
shown is agreed and that the current
nominees stay in post until annual
Council thank you is there a second
happy second time madam chair do members
agree with the leaders approach thank
you agenda item 18 changes to committees
panels and boards 2017 18
proportionality I call upon the leader
to make a proposal in respect of the
options as outlined in the report
proposed option one chair is there a
second happy to second that madam chair
does any member wish to propose an
alternative option counselor Piper
option two madam chair please
hey just a second is you have you got a
second up almost got thousands
do so those in favor of option B show
those in favor of that come one those in
favor of option one can't we have a show
of hands
those in favor of option two can we have
a show of hands and abstentions option
one has been agreed
Standards Committee and joint
transportation board I move that the
recommendation as set out in paragraph
three point two that the recommendation
is set out in paragraph three point two
of the report we agreed with the vice
chairman please second seconded madam
chairman don't mind mr. green nomination
of members to serve on committees group
leaders may wish to take this
opportunity to advise of changes to
their nominations to committees panels
and boards for the remainder of 2017-18
Council of Hayford do you wish to advise
on any nomination changes not committees
but I'd like to propose a chair of
vice-chair of so okay sorry okay I just
I just want to get down to popchips
sorry
councillor ever and Piper do you wish to
advise of any nomination change it thank
you madam chair option one having been
agreed we would need to add the
counselor John Dennis to the licensing
board and add counselors in the pots to
the overview and scrutiny committee
thank you Thank You councillor Wells do
you wish to advise or any nomination
changing lots of voice one nomination
change I can't say Judi della salute for
being remember the prank really it's
being on the reserve list and councillor
Bob Grove to be a member the plaintiff
is council matter face do you wish to
advise of any nomination changes not at
this point thank you thank you
election of vice-chairman election of
vice-chairman to the governance and
Audit Committee is there a nomination
councillor Beauford Thank You chair I'd
like to nominate councillor day please
is there a seconder
thank you madam chairman like to second
that nomination of council adage the Gov
ice show governs an audit are there any
further nominations councillor don't
remember it vice chair of governance an
audit
and that concludes the business for this
meeting of the council